The 2024 25 season sees the start of an
exciting new era for the UEFA Champions League,
UEFA Europa League and UEFA Conference League.
Taking part in the competitions,
though remains open and based on sporting merit.
For next season,
the current 32 team group stage will be replaced by
a league face
featuring 36 teams.
In each of UEFA's three men's club competitions,
each team will be drawn
against eight different opponents,
two from each of the four seating pots,
playing four at home and four away.
However, in the UEFA Conference League,
each team plays only six opponents,
one from each of the six seating pots.
Teams that finish in positions
1 to 8 qualify directly for the round of 16.
Teams ranked 9 to 24
must face each other in the knockout playoff round
to join the top eight in the round of 16.
Teams in positions
25 to 36 are eliminated from all competitions.
In the knockout phase,
all ties are contested home and away,
culminating in a single leg final.
In the new league formats,
every match, every goal,
every point and position in the ranking counts.
The new system
will ensure fast changing and unpredictable standings.
More matches between equally ranked teams
competing for crucial points,
with fans able to enjoy top clashes
right from the first matchday.
2024 A thrilling new future
a European club football.